pissing in a shower it's got to be
something everybody does right in a hot
shower I mean yeah but then we've even
we've recently dissected it even more do
you aim into the thing or do you just
like Let It Go on the wall I think I
that I think that that's a deciding
factor because I really think that like
if you any sort of class even if it's
just it's got to be in the direction of
the drink but if you're the other oh
here's the other thing if you're in the
other direction yeah like if where the
drain's not you're a piece of [__]
people then consider me a piece of [__]
oh you just [__] spray it around
it's not like a water it's not a [__]
waterfall
to rinse off a little bit